oh yeah like when somebody want one time
this was [ __ ] seven years ago when
people try to make you uncomfortable
with some [ __ ] that they're gonna bring
up I [ __ ] love that I [ __ ] eat
that [ __ ] for breakfast bro I eat it up
I love it
one time I was at the Laugh Factory this
was [ __ ] years ago and this girl came
up to me in front of other people and
said to me hey you asked me to hang out
on she was a facebook friend and we were
[ __ ] whatever she was like yeah you
you asked me to [ __ ] hang out on
MySpace or [ __ ] Facebook or something
and she thought she was gonna make me
embarrassed in front of her friends and
I [ __ ] it felt I felt like I became
the Hulk and I looked at her and I said
yeah yeah yeah I did yeah and I [ __ ]
hung it out there too I hung it out
there to dry dude
you're gonna hand me some [ __ ] wet
laundry dude you're gonna hand me some
[ __ ] wet laundry like I don't have a
[ __ ] clothesline are you kidding me
she thought she was gonna [ __ ] make
me feel uncomfortable in front of a
bunch of guys and girl she came with at
the Laugh Factory about hanging out and
she thought I was gonna [ __ ] stand
there with a wet sweater like Oh what am
I gonna do with this nope I [ __ ]
looked at her in the eyes and I said yup
and I threw that [ __ ] in the dryer and
guess what she felt [ __ ] stupid after
that she didn't know what to say
she goes up yeah dude you're gonna make
me feel uncomfortable
I got [ __ ] judo moves with that [ __ ]
man I've bombed in front of 450 people
at the Irvine improv do you think that
you're gonna come up in front of seven
people and say hey I remember you used
to ask me to hang out on Facebook or
myspace and
me feel Kobe you think I'm gonna do a
hard swallow for that give me all the
laundry I'll dry it [ __ ] all it's not
it's not gonna work dude it's not gonna
work I love it I love that [ __ ] I eat
I'll eat it I'll [ __ ] eat it do it
I'll eat it I'll keep it in my stomach
for four hours wait till it [ __ ]
forms [ __ ] it out and deliver it back to
you baby how about that
I just these people when people come up
to me hey man what's up what's up hey
you don't remember my name huh I look at
him and I say nope hey how about this be
memorable I think we talked about this
on the podcast that part but be bent be
memorable if I don't remember your name
it's your fault how about that if I
don't remember your name sure don't put
the blame on me man I'll dry laundry all
[ __ ] day
I have clotheslines for weeks
what's my name
you don't remember huh I step sturdy you
you understand I step closer to you and
you know when the handshake is supposed
to end it doesn't end there
I grip you can't get away hey what's up
what's up man how you doing all good hey
Chris you remember my name huh oh we do
it my hand I'm holding it I'm stepping
in and I'm
no that's how it should be it's not my
fault
I forgot your name I guess what if I met
[ __ ] the guy who cured cancer and he
said hey what's up I'm Rick I'll never
forget that guy's name
you know why memorable you know why
memorable okay if I remember some
[ __ ] dump truck of a man if some dump
truck of a man comes up and it already
knows me and I already met him and he
says what's my name huh hey who are you
who are you hey do you live in [ __ ]
Albuquerque cuz who are you
who the [ __ ] lives in Alcor Albuquerque
guys like that guys who you forget their
names
sorry Albuquerque had to pick some city
see you all that [ __ ] aren't working
[ __ ]
Albuquerque yeah dude you're not blaming
[ __ ] me for not knowing who the [ __ ]
you are
dah dah dah dah yah I'm loving it